[Música]
[Aplausos]
y el dolor miedo a perder la virilidad
mira dejar de ser macho a no conseguir
pareja
miedo a no tener más orgasmos en otras
normas elecciones al quirófano a la
anestesia
miedo a perder el respeto
ya lo desconocido ante todo me presento
soy el doctor fin cárcel jonathan
urólogo y andrólogo trabajo en el
sistema de salud público y privado
y la especialidad de las especiales yo
les he quizás no son tan conocidas
quizás hasta mucho a nuestros pacientes
las conocen cuando nos necesitan al
punto que me llegan a preguntar si
atendemos mujeres y por supuesto que
atendemos mujeres tienen riñón vejiga
uréter uretra y tranquilos ahí veo que
hay dos que se están moviendo con miedo
en el asiento no le voy a hacer un tacto
rectal a nadie solo viene a dar la
charla queden tranquilo con eso la
biología es mucho más amplia que eso se
encarga de la patología estructural
tumoral y hasta funcional de las vías
urinarias el aparato reproductivo y las
glándulas anexas masculinas
hasta ahí todo muy lindo pero la termino
de embarrar mucho más cuando yo que soy
andrólogo andrólogo médico de androides
médico de robots la neurología se
encarga de los trastornos que genera la
deficiencia de testosterona en el
envejecimiento masculino trastornos en
la sexualidad del hombre y trastornos en
el factor masculino en lo que es
fertilidad y es ahí donde a mí me toca
pararme de los dos lados del mostrador
viene un paciente o la que trae el
doctor estamos
hace dos años buscando tener un hijo y
no lo logramos bien otro paciente hola
que tal doctor vengo a verlo tengo tres
hijos y quiero cerrar la fábrica me
transformo en un hombre las dos caras
con uno voy a intentar que ese
espermatozoide se transforme en el
superman de los espermatozoides y con el
otro voy a hacer todo lo posible para
que ese espermatozoide nunca llegue a
juntarse con el óvulo de eso se trata mi
profesión médica tratar de ayudar al
paciente en su dolencia o inquietud con
respecto a su salud y tratar de ayudar a
solucionar ese problema y mejorar su
calidad de vida
hay hombres que quieren decidir cuántos
hijos tener hay mujeres que quieren
decidir cuántos hijos tener hay hombres
y mujeres que quieren decidir no tener
hijos y hay parejas que quieren decidir
cuándo cómo y cuántos hijos tener ese
concepto u oportunidad lo llamamos
planificación familiar la planificación
familiar es un derecho que tenemos todos
todas todas
y cuando hablamos de reproducción
estamos hablando también de la
sexualidad de las personas y de las
parejas no voy a hablar del cuento de la
semillita porque cálculo y espero que
todos sepan que no es real pero si da
ciertas funciones que tienen la
sexualidad por ejemplo la función
reproductiva una función de placer una
función comunicacional una función de
autoestima y me pregunto cómo podemos
hacer para separar estas funciones y por
ejemplo dejar de lado la función
reproductiva o sea por ejemplo tener
relaciones sexuales solo por placer sin
el riesgo de un embarazo que es casi
como poder comer sin la posibilidad
engordar
y me pregunto cuántas de las relaciones
sexuales que tenemos son realmente
buscando un embarazo cuantas cuántos
embarazos no deseados qué porcentajes
tenemos acá en argentina
estamos casi toda nuestra vida usando
métodos anticonceptivos para no lograr
ese embarazo quizás muchos en algún
momento de nuestras vidas quizás
decidimos ir en busca de seis hijos y
empiezan otras preguntas seré fértil el
85 90 por ciento de las parejas al cabo
de 12 meses de relaciones sexuales
frecuentes sin métodos anticonceptivos
logran el embarazo o sea logran que el
espermatozoide se junte con el óvulo año
2018 en la era que la gente compra
departamentos
autos por internet hasta se enamoran por
internet que nuevos métodos tenemos que
métodos anticonceptivos tenemos y en
cuales el hombre es realmente activo y
cuáles son para la mujer
veamos un poco la mujer tiene alrededor
de 10 métodos anticonceptivos
el hombre 2 preservativo que se lo pone
la mujer que se lo pone el hombre que se
lo pone después de penetrar que se lo
pone mal se le sale se rompe que pierde
la sensibilidad con él con el
preservativo
y la vasectomía claramente los hombres
la tenemos más fácil tan complicados
somos vídeo clínicamente que no se
desarrollan nuevos anticonceptivos
masculinos o será que no queremos que
aparezcan porque la industria
farmacéutica no pone más énfasis en el
desarrollo de investigaciones de nuevos
métodos anticonceptivos no serán
rentables
los hombres no estamos tan comprometidos
con la anticoncepción porque no tenemos
opciones no podemos dejar de un lado
factores y posturas machistas que todos
sabemos que existen por ejemplo la
postura que la mujer es la que se tiene
que preocupar porque la que queda
embarazada o factores de miedo del
hombre a perder la potencia sexual la
virilidad la masculinidad
veamos un poquito qué es esto de la
vasectomía a ver si podemos combatir ese
factor del desconocimiento que es el
gran factor
la vasectomía es un método
anticonceptivo que vamos a ver ciertas
nociones básicas de anatomía para que
todos podamos entender el hombre tiene
dos testículos que se encargan de formar
espermatozoides y sintetizar
testosterona esa formación de
espermatozoides es constante conviven
espermatozoides inmaduros con
espermatozoides maduros para luego a
través del conducto deferente juntarse
con las secreciones que producen las
glándulas la vesícula seminal y la
glándula prostática para terminar de
formar el semen que hacemos en la
vasectomía cortamos el conducto
deferente para que esos espermatozoides
no llegan a juntarse con las secreciones
por lo tanto vamos a tener semen sin
espermatozoides
los hombres y las mujeres tenemos claro
que el acceso anatómico hacia los
testículos es demasiado fácil está al
alcance de la mano los invito a los
hombres cuando lleguen a casa van a ver
que la salida del testículo hay como un
fideo finito duro es el conducto
deferente no lo hagan acá porque no da
pero realmente el gran factor es el
desconocimiento no nos conocemos
y ahora que ya somos anatomistas veamos
un poquito la técnica quirúrgica como lo
hacía antes el 'acceso anatómico es muy
fácil a través del escroto es una
cirugía ambulatoria con una leve
sedación local o una leve sedación
general se hace en una o dos incisiones
de entre 10 a 15 milímetros se toma el
conducto deferente se lo corta se
separan los cabos se electro con los
cabos se los liga y termino y bueno
puede haber algún saltarín por ahí y
preguntas que salen en la consulta para
evitar justamente estos siete días sin
relaciones sexuales 90 días por lo menos
usar métodos anticonceptivos hasta hacer
un nuevo cronograma y confirmar el éxito
de la cirugía o sea confirmar que en el
semen no hay espermatozoides y preguntas
típicas que salen del consultorio
respuestas típicas el hombre sigue
calculando sigue teniendo direcciones y
sigue teniendo orgasmos
acá lo ven había medio que el acceso
hacia los testículos está demasiado
fácil
como vemos es un método anticonceptivo
bastante interesante y por definición un
método anticonceptivo tiene que ser
reversible y para eso tenemos para el
arrepentido una cirugía que lo que busca
es unir los cabos pero ojo porque quizás
esa repentina habilitación de los cabos
no se produce o se produce de forma
parcial entonces no vamos a tener los
suficientes espermatozoides para lograr
el embarazo entonces qué es lo que mejor
le podemos ofrecer al paciente
información pre operatoria que el
paciente tenga la información para poder
tomar con seguridad las decisiones
sabiendo las consecuencias riesgos y
beneficios de esta práctica si el
paciente no está muy seguro se le puede
ofrecer la escribo preservación de
espermatozoides congelar espermatozoides
antes de la vasectomía y si no tenemos
como recurso también la biopsia
testículo para recuperar espermatozoides
del testículo ir directamente a la
fábrica y también usarlos en una terapia
de reproducción porque el testículo
sigue fabricando espermatozoides que se
van muriendo y el mismo cuerpo lo va
absorbiendo entonces con este breve
resumen creo que vamos viendo que
tenemos un método anticonceptivo
interesante reversibles bajo costo
seguro eficaz menos costo de la ligadura
de trompas y menos invasiva que la de
obra de trompas que es lo equiparable en
lo que es las mujeres entonces calculo
yo que se recontra de usar este método y
acá en este slide vemos los datos que
nos aporta el programa de nación de
salud sexual y procreación responsable y
vemos como en el año 2017
142 vasectomías sobre contra 14 mil 500
son ligaduras de trompas en hospitales
públicos en el año 2016 97 contra 12
1976 y en el año 2015 56 contra 14.183
asusta la brecha pero veamos en el vaso
medio lleno y está empezando a ver un
cambio estamos empezando a ver tiranía
años se están duplicando vayamos un
poquito más a fondo con las estadísticas
que en este país sabemos que no es lo
mejor que tenemos y tengamos en cuenta
que no todas las jurisdicciones
aportaron los números no todos los
hospitales dieron los números algunos
quizás dieron un estimativo y no están
los sanatorios clínicas privadas y los
médicos que los realizan de forma
particular y eso nos da un poco de aire
porque en la práctica privada uno está
notando la misma tendencia de
duplicación ya sea hasta me animo a
decir triplicación de vasectomías que se
está empezando a dar
y que está empezando a pasar que estamos
empezando a tener estos cambios
estadísticos acaso el reinado del macho
se está acabando ya la mujer no es la
única que se tiene que preocupar por la
anticoncepción que ir a comprar las
pastillas que acordarse de tomarla que
ir a comprar el parche ponerse el parche
cambiarse el parche ponerse el diu
hacerse la ligadura de trompas
te guste o no estés de acuerdo o no con
la ley de interrupción del embarazo que
se empezó a discutir acá en argentina el
tema se instaló y se empezó a revisar
cuál es el papel del hombre en la
anticoncepción se empezó a discutir en
las casas en los trabajos en las mesas
de familia en las camas y se empezó a
ver la vasectomía con un método como un
recurso interesante para evitar
embarazos no deseados y todas las
consecuencias que trae eso a nivel
social salud y económicas empezó a
aparecer información el gran enemigo del
desconocimiento y el gran aliado de la
educación sexual
empezó a aparecer información por
gracias a diferentes movimientos canales
medios y no me refiero solamente a
medios de comunicación y el hombre
empezó a llegar a la consulta pidiendo
hacerse la vasectomía y con un mayor
compromiso a la anticoncepción y la
planificación familiar
no por nada este tema hoy lo empezamos a
hablar acá me pregunto por qué no hay
políticas de salud públicas que
acompañen a esto no por nada este método
estamos viendo por qué es tan importante
es un método seguro eficaz y me preguntó
nuevamente por qué no hay políticas
públicas de salud que acompañen todo
esto durante mi formación
estuve hace cuatro años en la fundación
puigvert de barcelona donde se hacían
entre 10 a 20 vasectomías por semana
países como españa reino unido o canadá
se hacen más vasectomías que ligaduras
de trompas en muchos otros países la
brecha es mucho más chica y en países en
vías de desarrollo como nuestra
argentina tenemos estos números
me pregunto si podremos alguna vez
romper este paradigma me pregunto si
alguna vez podremos romper estas
estructuras patriarcales como médico
creo que tenemos que hacer un análisis
interno de en qué estamos fallando
creo que los urólogos los médicos de
familia médicos generalistas médicos
clínicos deberían preguntarle más al
hombre qué método anticonceptivo usa
porque no tenemos tanta llegada a la
población porque los ginecólogos y
obstetras no se lo sugieren a sus
pacientes a sus parejas porque hay
urólogos que se niegan a realizarlo y
esto va más allá de lo religioso porque
llegan a la objeción de conciencia con
la ley 26.130 todo paciente mayor de
edad apto y otorgando su consentimiento
ser capaz perdón no aptos otorgando su
consentimiento se alcanza para que se
pueda hacer la vasectomía entonces ya
sabiendo todo esto
les pregunto sobre todo a los hombres
que estamos esperando para
comprometernos más con la anticoncepción
que estamos esperando para exigir más
salud pública sobre este tema más
política de salud pública que estamos
esperando para exigir educación sexual y
a los hombres les quiero preguntar
nuevamente
a qué le tenemos miedo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]